[Musique]
bon ceux de mabo olten le mot bonne fête
les mamans j'espère les enfants que vous
avez tous fêter votre maman aujourd'hui
et que vous lui avez offert des cadeaux
et des fleurs et celle ci et pour la
maman de nicolas est pas propre
héros on peut peut-être
bonne
bonne fête les mamans
[Musique]
respectives mais pas bois n'est jamais
trop tard pour bien faire
et on lui en faire des tas de cadeaux
une icône à l'achat qu'une belle chanson
n'est pas premier accompagné au piano me
ce merveilleux
qui va t'amener ajaccio oh oui ça me
ferait tellement plus d'accord mais
après on va se coucher attends je me
mets au piano la
gema
mans c'est pour toi que je chante
c'est pour toi que je chante aujourd'hui
toi toujours
si douce et souriante
toi qui est
ma petite maman chérie
chara pour le fête des mères
je t'ai acheter ce bouquet
que j'allais quelques primeurs
et je
tom de tout mon coeur
chers amis
c'est d'un grand jour de fête
moi je
très fort te faire plaisir
usa mort sur mon satisfait que sa queue
j'ai encore de dire je te promets que je
vais être sage je te promets
trop puissant
[Musique]
trop gentil quand tu as des louvre
et bien manger pour devenir grand
charme en juin au prix en cash et
toi ce ce petit complément
de tout mon coeur je ne dis pas non
de ton coeur
on ne
[Musique]
bonne fête maman
tenait les petits vous lui donnerez
aussi c'est rose à votre maman de la
part de nounours
merci nicolas
années 90 on va se coucher tout seuls
comme des grands bonne nuit le plus
[Musique]
alors nounours tu en fais une tête
nicolas et pimprenelle n'ont pas été
gentil avec toi aussi
patron me je suis russe je pense à ma
vieille maman ours le theule moto rose
projet lui souhaite sa fin allons mon
gros nounours en route bonne nuit les
enfants n'oubliez pas d'être toujours
très gentil avec votre maman rouge
embrasser la pierre en forme et feu de
pur
[Musique]
oh